this past weekend
[Music]
through the night I'm not going to sing
it man I'm going to let it uh I'm just
going to let it continue to be there in
the back of our head and in our hearts
welcome to this past weekend I'm Theo
von it is Monday May 29th sorry I got a
little bit of a frog in my throat they
say that and I'd hate to be the man
whoever first had that you know because
it was probably an actual diagnosis at
some point you know I mean that had to
be sheer hell you know so thankfully
it's just for me I know these days is
just a bit of a niche but I'm coming to
you live or currently live but maybe not
when you're hearing this I'm coming to
you live on Memorial Day
we want to wish everybody a happy
Memorial Day if anybody has served or or
has a family member that has served
thank you thank you for my freedom my
job as a comedian is freedom of speech
so that is my job is directly affected
by the sacrifices made by those who have
who have defended our freedom and have
served our country I'm a big big support
of the military as much as I can be I
actually almost thought for a little
while that only people who have served
in the military should be able to vote
or that their votes should count for
more there was just a thought that I had
at some point to just kind of pops into
my head but happy Memorial Day to
everybody I am here in Tampa I'm coming
to you from Tampa and before we get into
it I'm going to let you know some dates
really quick just so you know I have
shows in Pittsburgh next weekend then
I'm at Colusa casino near Chico
California then I'm in New York City
Nashville Stark County Illinois San
Diego and Las Vegas all by the end of
July and you can check out those dates
at Theo von comm slash tour t oh you are
but I'm happy to be here in Tampa man
thank you guys for joining me today and
happy Memorial Day or whatever day
you're listening making sure this is on
whatever day you're listening to this
show it's been an interesting week I
spent some time with some fans and
Friends of the show that came out a
couple took it took a couple of young
fellows to Chili's yesterday for dinner
I thought that they were you know lovers
actually some young younger gentlemen
nice skin and you know lean arms and
just supple supple looking guys but nice
you know and when I'm had you know kind
of fancy hairdos and I thought that they
maybe were lovers but they're just
cousins so we had a nice time and had
some salmon and enjoy each other's
company there at the Chili's chain
restaurant here in outside of Tampa down
here in Florida and this is Florida and
you know that you're familiar with that
what else a nice fella named Ned which I
didn't know was a name still it's like
Edie but with no you know took me to
wait Jim we went to the crunches Fitness
you know and we had a nice time still
can't really move my neck very well so
I'm a little necked up but Ned got that
neck workout on point dude and we had a
nice time and those are people that I
met at the shows here on a holiday and
express as you can see behind me if
you're watching on a youtube you can see
the beautiful curtain egde moved a
couple of lamps in the room so that I'm
getting enough light so this is going to
be what it's going to be today guys it's
tough when I'm out here on the road it's
midnight I got me some coffee
I'm flying back to Los Angeles in about
six and a half hours but I'm happy to be
here with you and happy Memorial Day to
you guys I hope it's been a great
weekend hope you're enjoying time with
your loved ones are with yourself you
know but I do hope that you're staying
active what else
medical lesbians here in the pool some
adult lesbians down here in the swimming
pool at the Holiday Inn Express out here
off a corporate Boulevard and we I
didn't see one
hiding in the corner smoking weed kind
of ducked out under some trees kind of
that we're looming over the gate so I
thought it was just this one lady who
was out there in the pool and she kept
asking me when I was coming to the pool
again like she wanted to kind of set up
a little date and then I heard up her
lady chiming in the distance you know
tough for lesbian you know more of a
sturdier gal and and then I realized
they were both pretty jacked and they
kind of invited me to spend time with
them you know if I wanted to hang out
you know in at 4:30 in the afternoon I
mean that's really that's a no Memorial
weekend they're celebrating you know
they're getting you know letting their
you know letting their curtains hang if
you will you know letting them letting
the balls drop you know and they wanted
me to do some maybe sexual activity or
spend some time relaxing you know they
asked me what kind of television
programs I liked and if I wanted to you
know you know kind of spend time with
them and almost because one of them it
looked as if she'd served in the
military she had some military tattoos
on her arm she was pretty jacked shaved
head black woman or African American and
then another white older kind of
granddaddy of a lady and then I realized
that if I were going to get in a
threesome with these gals that I would
be the woman that was the crazy part man
I would be you know or I would be the
service animal if you will you know I'd
be the seeing-eye dog you know I'd be
probably the one you know the pig that's
getting roasted I wouldn't be one of the
spigots I had a feeling that these girls
were ready to put some you know to take
some of maybe some gender resentments
they may have out on me
and almost almost got involved with them
just sheerly out of it being Memorial
Day weekend and wanting to do whatever I
could for America or you know kind of
give back give back out of myself out of
my time to be of service with these gals
but then I chose not to you know because
I just
didn't want to be involved and I almost
was a little bit nervous you know but we
had a good time man
had a good time with those ladies and I
passed on the sex sexual opportunities
what else I ate a lot of barbeque man
ate a lot of barbecue dude went to the
same barbecue place five times and and
it's uh it's a lot of men in there
eating barbecue you know it kind of
reminds me of like a Carl's jr. I don't
know if you've ever spent time in a
Carl's jr. it's a Hardee's basically I
mean it it's a Hardee's in disguise
they're the same thing
Carl's jr. is just a Hardee's in
disguise so if you see a Carl's jr. know
that it's really a Hardee's inside they
just have really packed it up
differently but at a Carl's jr. a lot of
lonely men eat at Carl's jr. you know
because they push these big burgers
these man burgers these man meals you
know meals for a man and a lot of you
see a lot of lonely men eating in there
cause I used to go get a turkey sandwich
over there a lot of times in the evening
and I've spent a lot of time being
lonely and so it's no it's no surprise
that I ended up with my kind you know
with uh with my you know with those
types of people and the men are in there
eatin Flo and they're sitting by
themselves
and-and-and single mini slow lonely men
eat slow watch a lonely man II take his
time no hurry
married man they eat you know eat faster
they got to get back to business because
they got a lot to do and people hold
them accountable before they die so they
got to eat fast but a single man eats
slow they slow in at the Carl's jr. I'd
always find myself sitting in there and
I'd look around and it's all just lonely
dudes and they're eating so go in there
go to a Carl's jr. you'll see and and it
kind of made me nervous
because you find yourself looking around
and then you're locking eyes with
another fella and you're trying to eat
and you got your mouth open
and it made me feel just it kind of
brought some feelings up inside of my
body you know it made me feel a little
bit not gay but it made me feel like
something gay could occur something gay
was lurking you know a homoerotic
activity because think about it if you
if you're eating something okay go go
with me on this because some of you guys
are probably like you know what is he
talking about if you're eating something
right if you look at if you want lock
eyes with another man it's nothing right
but now open your mouth and then lock
eyes with another man it's different if
you have your mouth closed and you're
looking at another man that's one type
of feeling you have your mouth open and
you're locking eyes with another man
there's a different type of feeling
there I'm not saying it's wrong I'm just
saying that it riles up kind of some
more homoerotic thoughts and that's what
I would notice at Carl's jr. because I
was in there with these big sandwiches
you know having to get your mouth open
big and then you're looking around
because that's nature you know being
natural and you'll lock eyes with
another lonely man and you'd have a
flare-up of something just a spark of
some light eroticism I felt like at
times and not that I was going to act on
anything like that but it just became an
element in the air that there was some
you know that something could occur that
something could occur and this is one of
the reasons why I think Quiznos went out
of business
Quiznos good sandwiches member black
olives maybe some cooked ham you know
they got the lettuce on there and
sometimes they cook it and then they
change to not cook it and they went back
to cooking it but one of the reasons I
think Quiznos went out of business was
because that toasted bread okay you get
that toasted bread you can't eat that
easily you got to open your mouth you
know you got to go wide on that toasted
bread and as a man when you open that
mouth and you're in there and you're
looking around and seeing other men I
think it subconsciously made a lot of
men
nervous or it made him uncomfortable if
they were you know if they were you know
extremely straight hardcore
heterosexuals and it probably made them
nervous you know Here I am with my mouth
open constantly because you have to open
your mouth to eat that cooked bread that
that you know that bread gets really
hearty crusty you know that bread gets
tight tight on the outside tight tight
and you got to open your mouth and I
find that for me it would get there were
times it was just uncomfortable not that
there's anything wrong with you know
somebody feeling gay or being gay or
acting gay you know but there were times
when I just noticed it was unexpected
because sometimes others wanted a
sandwich I didn't want to have to deal
or feel anything that was homoerotic
when I was just trying to have a meal
and that's something that I found but
was an issue with Quiznos because it was
more than a meal
it was stirring up feelings that
sometimes you're okay with thinking
about the feelings but sometimes you
don't want to do that at lunchtime same
thing with eating yogurt yogurt do can
somebody get a grasp on this yogurt
every time I open a yogurt might just be
me maybe I'm at a bad altitude but it
kind of skeet out a little it busts out
you know like it's bust in a just a
light nut or just a belts like a little
bit of it kind of shoots out onto the
table or onto the floor or on my arm or
shirt and it's just it makes me feel
sometimes uncomfortable you know there's
nothing wrong with that feeling but it
just makes me feel like there's more to
it you know and it just makes you wonder
if these yogurts have that much feeling
in them then they need to relieve these
yogurts at the dairy they need to open
them there once and then send them to me
you know because I feel like a lot of
these yogurts are showing up with
feelings and then the second I crack in
they bust out and you know I'm trying to
get through the day you know if I'm a
straight man I'm trying to get through
the day and not deal with that you know
that dairy skeet
if you will so those are some feelings
that I have sometimes about about what's
going on
with some of those food areas and and
yet amp I went to the same place
barbecue I went and watched a lot of
softball man that softball was exciting
dude a softball was exciting wasn't it
and I watched LSU beat Florida State and
that was a great they came back from
behind and UCLA Ole Miss us a lot of
great games I softballs exciting man you
know but I'll say this if you are a gay
male and you're looking to meet straight
men who are lonesome go to Carl's jr. go
to Carl's jr. because there are men in
there eating big sandwiches they got to
get that mouth open and you lock eyes
with them
you know and it can happen and I
remember being in Carl's jr. and they
had up some of these guys I think this
is kind of like a gay pickup move
they'll watch your choose cycle they'll
see how you're chewing you know and
they'll get on the same choo cycle as
you and if they see you chew in a
certain way they start chewing a certain
way and that's like a code you know kind
of like how at the airport that governor
or whatever from Minnesota was doing the
foot tap you know the under the table or
what under the at the urinal it's like
that if a man does your choose cycle
doing the same choose as you own food
that means that he's looking to be you
know sentimental or he's looking to feel
fancy you know so just be cognizant that
that's going on there's nothing wrong
with it if that's what you want but that
that synchronized chewing is that's a
pick-up move you know and sometimes they
got fellas out there that will want to
do you know different things with your
wiener games or something or just just
lay there maybe hold you or anything but
it can happen
it can happen at Carl's jr. so just want
to let you guys know that but I was at
side-splitter comedy in Tampa and I'm so
excited
berg next weekend years ago I got a blow
job over there in Pittsburgh behind a
giant eagle grocer first time I went
there many years ago and I got pinkeye
from that and giant eagle that's just a
Kroger
that's a Kroger in disguise so I don't
know if you guys knew that or not but a
happy Memorial Day I want to wish
everybody that happy Memorial Day it's
it's a big day man
Memorial Day you noticed in memory of
all the people that have given their
lives for our country that's what it's
about millions millions millions of men
and women that have given their lives in
1971 it started up as a officially
recognized holiday and and I want to say
I think that it's lost a meaning to a
lot of Americans and I noticed it myself
last year I was fortunate enough to
happen upon a Memorial Day Parade I
didn't plan on going but I ended up
seeing one and that really hit me in the
heart and and if you don't do something
like that or go to a graveyard where all
the flags are up I did that I can't run
from that on the 4th of July last year
if it was Memorial Day but I went on one
of those days and really I mean your
heart just fills up with the realities
of sacrifice that have come in into play
over time to make America what it is you
know because I feel like we've kind of
we've gotten comfortable man and a lot
of people just think it's a holiday now
which is just a day off you know in my
time growing up there was you know there
are there was Desert Storm there was a
there was some more America seemed like
it was more of a thing you know the red
white and blue the pride does seem like
to be more of that and this could be
just this is just my view you know but
there just seemed to be more of that you
know there seemed to be more of a having
American flags outside it wasn't weird
and now it seems to me like America has
become like a United Nations meeting
first and then America second you know
it's like now you have the national
anthem but it's not even about
the national anthem anymore it's about
somebody doesn't want to stand for it
and I'm not talking about the NFL I'm
talking about just like in a regular
classroom or they want to outlaw it or I
don't know it's just become it's almost
become this international hub that's
what America has become kind of like a
place where other people just stop in to
make money
it doesn't seem sometimes like it has
the same effect the same red white and
blue tuefel notion if you will then it
had back in the day you know and I think
something that's because of comfort you
know it's been a long time since we've
had a real serious war that we have all
firsthand seen the effects of loss and
the real effects of war like a lot of
other countries see more often you know
I mean we've been very fortunate I mean
I mean I think it's I don't even know
how long it's been since we have one on
American soil it could be the civil war
but I think there were some Wars after
that maybe but we don't see that you
know we don't see firsthand the effects
of it you know it hasn't been since you
know World Wars 1 and 2 we've lost vast
amounts of humans so it's not like
there's that constant reminder a huge
reminder and we've gotten comfortable
you know I think a lot of us in America
have gotten comfortable we just see
Memorial Day now is just like a barbecue
a day off people forget what it's about
and sometimes that is notice that that's
the thing across America now it's just
we've lost a sense of American pride it
feels like sometimes and maybe that's
also I just live in Los Angeles that is
this you know this growing pot of you
know like acting as if it's they're not
even a part of America but once
something serious happens once there's a
serious war or something like that that
puts everybody's feelings back in a
perspective I think you're going to see
a lot more people getting back on the
American bus you know just a lot more
people realizing that it's not just
about you know all these luxuries and
comforts that we have that that there's
a lot of that that we've been very
fortunate we've had a lot of sacrifice
that's occurred and I'm not saying I've
seen that in my lifetime really but
did seem like when I was young that
there was more of that and you know I
don't want there to be a war for us to
get back to that but it makes me wonder
sometimes like if the in the in the in
the universe you know there's always a
high and a low there's always a yin and
a yang and it makes me worry sometimes
that if we get too comfortable and we
don't have some humility and we don't
have some pride that something is going
to happen in the world to correct that
so that makes me a little bit nervous
but also you know I'd love to have
something that bonded us together you
know I don't want to wish a tidal wave
on half of America but I'd love there to
be something that you know just makes us
feel some pride again and maybe that's
just something I need to work on within
myself over the years I've had the honor
and the privilege of going to do some
tours overseas and I say tours lightly
overseas for the military you know I
think five times I've gotten to go
abroad to different bases around the
world actually let me think Spain
England Saigon no Singapore a bunch of
different Portugal the Azores or
somewhere them in the I don't even know
Central America [ __ ] I don't know did
I need a map damn I'm a dumb American
but I had two great moments going
overseas and I'm gonna tell you about
those right now and then we'll get to
some questions I'm going to tell you
about those right now then we'll get to
some questions
one of them was I was in Guantanamo Bay
I went to Guantanamo Bay and I got to do
stand-up and I'd only been doing
stand-up about three or four years and I
was excited and I was nervous we flew
out of Fort Lauderdale out of a private
Airport at like midnight it's about a
two hour plane ride I think and I just
remember we came up on the it looked
like it is huge diamond just glowing in
the distance and it was all dark because
we tried to fly around Cuba
the airspace deal where you can't fly
directly over it
so we had to fly around Cuba and and
then we just drop like disease like
flight tactics where you drop really
fast so you're it's just the way you
come in and out of some of these bases I
guess and next thing you know we land
and we're on Guantanamo Bay man we're at
Gitmo and it was amazing I mean it was
just amazing to see they had I think
around like fifteen or sixteen hundred
troops down there that a couple of golf
courses some beautiful beaches we had
about nine women I remember that very
few women they had this term Gitmo
pretty Gitmo pretty was that once you
were on Gitmo if you're a woman you just
became beautiful out of sheer numbers
you know it's like and I remember the
first night we got there I saw some
girls there wasn't super attracted to
him by the third night I was like holy
[ __ ] I will damn well marry miss Rhonda
right now I know she's 55 but I will
marry her and it was amazing it was just
amazing how you know how hot these gals
got and I actually ended up getting a
[ __ ] from a GAO down there making
love actually I'm sorry
making love getting a [ __ ] with a
crop you know from an actual crotch of a
woman down there in Guantanamo Bay who
had a grenade in the trunk of her car
and that's not a that's not a fictional
term that's not a sex move or something
she had an actual grenade in her car
that she showed me in the trunk and then
we you know had some you know did some
premarital sex you know even though we
weren't even getting married it was just
meeting up but I think it still
classifies as that and then another time
and I'm sorry if I have a cold tonight
guys I just got a lot going on in the in
this in the plumbing and myface plumbing
another time I was at this base called
Camp Arif John and that is in Kuwait and
that's a popular base where a lot of
people heading in
to Iraq or Iraq would fly there first
and I guess get acclimated or it was
like a main hub to get in and out of
there and we were doing a lot of bases
and small forward operating bases for
the military around around Iraq and in
in in Iraq and all these small little
bases and and it was awesome was an
amazing experience like I'm amazed that
that the military lets us come and do
that I mean we were riding in Blackhawks
and had people with you know machine
guns and we're riding in these rav4s and
and and you just got to see what these
with the service men and women's lives
were like and also how diverse the
military is like you know I grew up with
this mindset of this GI Joe type of
thing you know where everybody was white
and and one guy was kind of beige but
the military is extremely diverse and
that was really cool to see I was super
cool just to see it man just to realize
that you know how diverse how diverse it
is and we were at this base Arif John
and and there's there's this we're in
the gym in the gym that a nice fitness
center I mean it was nice man I mean
this place was really really nice and we
stayed there I think like 3 or 4 nights
and they had we were in the gym lifting
weights and this alarm goes off right
and I'd heard the alarm the day before
and at that point it's an alarm where if
something comes over the base over one
of the walls of the base there's like a
sensor and an alarm goes off all over
base just to let you know that something
has flown into the base like a
projectile of sorts this is what I was
told anyhow and at that point you just
wait because you don't know what it is
you don't know where it's going to land
right and I remember somebody told me
that it happened we're in the cafeteria
and that happened well the next time it
happened I was at the gym and I hear it
and everybody who's what lifting weights
and everything
walking around just stops and there's
this moment where I'm just waiting for
something to land like I'm could have
been a missile since I have a projectile
I don't know could have been a you know
that is busted a bird carrying it was
ecstasy pills could have been a bird
could have been a bird a falcon you know
a nightingale or something carrying damn
you know uh
you know um cyanide or something but
there's something that came into the
base and you're standing there literally
you lock eyes of people and you don't
know if this might be your last moment
on earth I mean you're just waiting to
see if something lands and that was that
was unbelievable to me man it's one of
the scariest moments ever had and it
happened a few more times over the next
you know week or two that we were out
there in these different bases but there
was just this moment where everybody
stopped and stood and it's like there's
this it's like a roulette wheel you know
and you're a number and this bomb or
projectile or whatever it is is the ball
and you're just kind of waiting to see
if it's it could be a rock or a Molotov
cocktail that some you know some
insurgent just hummed over the fence
into the base they could be something as
simple as that
and that's what they said happens a lot
but it could also be somebody fired up
RPG in the debate like you just don't
know and that was just unbelievable to
stand there and just like be waiting to
see if your life was going to end or if
something tragic was going to happen
it's pretty pretty baffling and the fact
that these men and women just you know
do that constantly and that's just one
of the little things that they endure
those moments of uncertainty wow it was
pretty amazing so I'm just going to have
just a brief moment of silence right now
for for everyone that's uh that suffered
a loss of a family member or just for
the loss of any of our servicemen and
women
ya feelin fortunate today I'm going to
try to remind myself all day to feel
fortunate all right guys let's get into
some calls man and actually the hotline
now you can also text to it I'm going to
give you that number and if you have if
you want any basic life suggestions
that's what I offer all I can offer is
my experience if I can relate to
something that you're going through that
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three you can text into
that or you can call into that and I'm a
new um I'm going to go into a couple of
texts we got some text this week excuse
me again some coffee we got some text
this week and I'm going to crack into
those right now here we go hey Theo it's
your boy James from Maine I have a
situation with the lady I met recently I
met her on tinder tinder and Maine must
be very I mean damn it I bet there's
missing pets on there I bet there's a
karma you probably find karma on tinder
in Maine I mean I bet it's few and far
between I bet everything's on there I
met her on tinder so naturally I figured
she didn't expect anything too serious
two weeks after I and he says ate that
ass is the term that this James from
Maine is using she's still texting me
every day acting like we got a future we
got a future so James seems a little
urban up there from Maine if you're a
badass anyhow in addition she's super
religious and I've never been to church
okay well you haven't been to church but
if you've eaten the ass if somebody is
super religious dude I mean that's the
devil that's the devil's empanada right
there brother so I don't know you may
need to go to church now I've never been
to church I feel bad for the poor girl
she's a sweet her she's a sweetheart and
I'm a dirty dog
I want to end it because one I'm not
that into her and two I'll probably end
up breaking her heart any advice on how
to end things before they get too
serious bro stay funky brah James and
then he actually misspelled James the
second time so that's that's main for
you dude a lot of weed up there a lot of
hidden weed you know when you misspelled
James assets' but if you're eating
Church ass James you know that's that's
a serious move man you know that's I
mean you are gelling with that Narnia
hole you know and you're being wild
that's real stuff right there you're
doing you know and she's probably and
I'm assuming you're doing that because
she doesn't want to do sex because she's
probably saving herself for marriage or
for you know someone who's not trying to
be a dirty dog so you should probably
you know it sounds like you want to let
her go are you just looking you know for
affirmation from me I guess I'm a little
bit confused you know I mean I would
probably text her and let her know you
know I mean you snacking on the dark
arts brother you know I mean that's I
mean that's that booty communion that
you're getting into and that's serious
so I'd be a man I'd text her you know I
just say hey this isn't for me I got the
devil in me put it on the level that she
can understand us and that's going to
make her feel you know if you just say
I'm not into you that kind of can hurt
her feelings she'll wonder why but if
you say I got the devil in me you know
then I got Lucifer living just right up
under my skin then she might know then
that okay well he's not the guy for me
it let's almost what lets her make a
little bit of the choice you know so
that could maybe make her feel a little
bit better or just totally you want to
be single because that's also what it
kind of sounds like and I'll notice this
man when I tell somebody the truth
I hear that truth as well whereas if I
just ring it around and just BS and all
this then you can live in that space for
years and I tell you that from
experience man I mean there were you out
there with some girls I would text
along four years we're going to meet up
and then they would like we're going to
meet up but we would nobody would ever
follow through it was just this empty
universe of you know and maybe
occasionally catch up but it was just
this empty universe of trying to hold on
and not let go and and sometimes you
just got to shoot them straight because
you'll feel better and you'll also hear
whatever you say if you say I want to be
single right now and you let someone
know that and you'll feel it if you're
texting them the truth you'll not want
to hit Send
it's almost bizarre sometimes but if you
do then you're going to hear that as
well and that will resonate in you and
then you'll start you won't feel like
such a dirty dog if you you'll start to
come to women in the in the beginning
before you're you know chewing on their
buttocks or you know being you know
being wild like that because that
animals do that you know my buddy gots
three or four dogs and they're always
chewing on each others butts and you
know being erotic and stuff with their
noses in each other's buds so you're
going to be able to you're going to be
able to let her know straight up and
then you'll in the future when you meet
a girl you'll just be able to say yeah
I'm enjoying being a single right now
and it probably just put you in a better
place so I would just do that man I'd
shoot her straight but that is it all
right we got another one
what's up do its Jason from Mission
Viejo I'm 40 and going to college for
the first time I was married young out
of high school and never went to college
that's okay bruh you know but luckily
landed great paying jobs eventually
divorced after six years I worked the
next ten years in the marijuana industry
making more great money until I was
raided and lost everything I guess it's
still an industry if you could get
raided
you know it sounds like an illegal
industry but still an industry and it's
just illegal by the law you know at
these points I think marijuana certainly
has medicinal values for sure
making more grant money calls rate I did
60 days jail time
damn dude that's awesome it's exciting
that was five years
go and I realized it's time to go back
to school yeah it sounds like you've had
five years since then it's been on your
mind
good I'm glad you're getting back in I
have the drive and desire but I'm a
little nervous about being 40 and going
to college any overall suggestions
Thanks do Jason bro I mean you can think
of this one
I'd watch old school right out of the
gate man you watch old school that's
going to put you at least in like a
chill fun mindset you know that and make
it probably cool to other people and
[ __ ] you know you could also start a
blog or an Instagram about it you know
real life oldschool that could be your
handle real life old-school and just
share like what it's height should be
like a 40 year old dude in college you
know I would say from I went to seven
different colleges six actually and and
I remember a lot of we get a lot of
older people that came back in and I'm
glad we're discussing this Jason because
I consider going back to school you know
I'd like to go back to school to take
some writing classes and I have over the
years but I'd like to really go full bra
full bore and enroll at some point here
hopefully pretty soon but we'll see but
I would say don't be like a know-it-all
in class we had like some you know old I
almost had senior citizen but you know
like some junior citizens I guess 40 we
have some junior citizens that came in
that you know we're like know-it-alls
you know I wouldn't do that you know I
mean I do [ __ ] to stay chill bruh you
know I talked to hot chicks call someone
a [ __ ] bruh if you have to you know
throw up a gang sign if you have to rep
aset you know even if it's [ __ ]
people don't know that you know I'm
assuming that it's community college so
there will be people there that are
definitely worse off than you bro you
know probably people that just got out
of prison you know I got a buddy who
went to Community College he's a
physical therapist now he can't even
read he cannot read dude like I don't
even email them you know I calls only
Falls only and he's working in Ohio
making decent money so you just got to
get through this whatever your the
degree you're trying to do you got to
get through it all so don't come in with
like a like a shitty looking backpack
that was one thing like if you were like
a junior citizen then people that were
that age and stuff always you could tell
because their backpack was like all like
some lady had all her [ __ ] in like a
briefcase or something like lady you
know like half the people here trying to
be mechanics I guess it's it's you know
it's junior college like it you know
Community College so don't do that don't
do other [ __ ] that old people like our
adults man I say old people look very
good three years older than me so I'm
not judging or misusing terminology so I
get a dope bag type of one that's at
least kind of hip you know what else
dude just eat like eat like at lunch
sometimes but also you can bring your
food sometimes but don't be that older
person that like brings mad like a
[ __ ] crock-pot and [ __ ] in a class
and like like butter like butter and all
their bread and [ __ ] and quite like
chill the [ __ ] out like old people
always want to show their experience
when they get into class like just chill
you know I'd see what other people are
doing before you make a lot of moves you
can kind of see where you can fit in
also you can tell the kids used to sell
weed especially if this is in California
that's something that you know it's
normal in California to say that you
know if this were in you know if this
were in like East Greenwich Connecticut
and might not be the coolest thing to
say people might think you're a criminal
but you could tell these kids you were
criminal tell them you did time you know
that carries a lot of weight at
Community College because some of the
kids at Community College will be
straight up [ __ ] Muppet ass lurkers
bro you know straight up freakin chances
dude straight up dude you know dudes it
would eat their own ball skin probably
if they could so you know you just want
to be killed you want to fit in you're
going to have patios there you can have
strugglers but i rep a gang if you have
to represent you know that no one has
ever heard of wear a bandana bro
I wear a bandana take it easy don't try
too hard get in where you fit in that's
what I would do because that's funny I
get nervous about it too but the number
one thing I get nervous about is having
a shitty backpack or just having one
that's like way out of touch you know
because you don't want to just you just
want to make it easier on yourself like
you don't want people talking [ __ ] to
you and about you you know about you is
kind of find you don't know but to you
like you know you'll bro where'd you get
that [ __ ] satchel bro you know your
dog you got a Cana so kind of Soga wagon
with that satchel you don't want all
that [ __ ] man
you want to be able to feel your joy and
let your joy out of your body and enjoy
yourself but cool man I I'd love for you
to let us know how it's going call back
in in a few weeks or after you start and
if you could send that send in that
bandanna Pig bro I'd love to see you
reppin a set at Community College maybe
a great follow up because I'm curious as
well so if you could do that for me
Jason from Mission Viejo I would
appreciate it man and good luck good
luck to you do it's going to be exciting
I mean look you're going to have you're
going to be able to meet people probably
have lovely ladies to look at every day
or lovely men if you like men and and
there's going to be some joy there so I
hope you find some of that man good luck
or we got one call that came in I'm
going to hit this call now here's one
thing I'm going to say we've got a lot
of great calls that have come in I'm not
making this episode too intense today
because it's it's Memorial Day man this
day isn't even about me this day is
about America so but in typical America
fashion Memorial Day is a day you know a
lot of people a lot of car sales auto
sales right and somehow on the hotline
number which again I'll give to you it's
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and I want some calls anybody
that's ever if somebody out there is
missing an appendage I've always kind of
wondered what some of that life is like
and I'd love to hear more about that so
if somebody out there is missing an
appendage and wants to you know call in
about that and let us know if it is
really bad or if it's not that
bad and some of the you know the if you
can find a humor in it and I'm not
trying to make fun of it
but if you can find humor in it in
missing an appendage if you've lost an
appendage I'd love to know about that
you know we're lost an eye or an eye
because that's wild I think but we have
one more right here
and this person this is just America
dude somebody got the number on accident
somehow and called from a auto
dealership dude listen to this [ __ ]
there's one of the messages that I got
bro and this is just so fitting of
America right here Cristiano messages
for Theo von my name is Randy brown and
I'm with the internet sales department
at race board in Bossier City Louisiana
I was calling in regard to research for
the 2017 Mustang he's calling in regard
to a search for a 2017 Mustang first of
all dude I've had a car for three years
have certainly not searched for a
Mustang well I could have been a horse
could have been looking up horses but
there's no way I looked for an
automobile
so that's while do but Randy listen to
this listen to this [ __ ] Muppet here
we go hitting the hot line dude about
this onward well let you know we have
several Mustang abut models available
and stock here at race order I do
superior 28:51 bit in road in Bossier
City oh that's awesome
Randy that's only about 1800 miles from
me I'll scoot right over bro and if you
have any questions regarding any of them
I can into them for you
also if you'd like to schedule a time to
combine just love the Mustang with our
internet sales manager miss Karen or
with any member of sales team each miss
Karen your internet I mean you always
have to love it it's so Louisiana your
internet sales manager is Miss Karen
dude throw in a last name bro tempt me a
little so I'm just saying like Randy
brown dude I don't I don't hate you but
you're just you're infringing on my
privacy bro you know I don't want a
Mustang
want to 2017 Mustang I want to fly to
Bose your city to get one bro perfect
you're using I can assist you in city
the time to do so that's convenient for
your schedule so if you have any
questions if you'd like to schedule a
time for a test ride please feel free to
call me in three one eight six eight six
seven three zero zero and I'm an
extension 160 Eminem friend you're an
extension six six six for me brother
okay I just don't need it
I appreciate the initiative but damn
dude you don't even know each other and
listen to him he must have heard the
outgoing voicemail when he called
offering basic life suggestions and
Randy [ __ ] Braun from Ray forward and
Bossier still hitting me up one upon a
test off a 20-17 Mustang with Miss Karen
miss Karen dude is that is that a
kindergarten teacher it sound like a
lunch lady dude come on
bro you're not going to do good business
like that you sound like you are like
only have seven pints of blood in your
body dude you saw me give emphysema but
you're only 32 years old get it together
alright Randy brown you know I want you
to call back at some point R and if you
ever hear this I want you to call back
and I want you to entice me to buy a
[ __ ] forward or whatever it is from
damn ray forward yeah that's a Ford
unless that's the guy's met its rate
forward Ford Mustang and look yeah I
want you to call back and put some
[ __ ] nuts on it dude not this
[ __ ] if you want to come and the
internet sales team and Miss Karen
come on man my god brother but that's
America man and that's part of honestly
what Memorial Day is has come to you
know if that dude wants to say we're
having a Memorial Day sale salute the
[ __ ] troops bro and here a little bit
of this [ __ ] in the background dude
[Music]
don't just call with your [ __ ] you
know I'm not sure anyway so yeah so
that's a call we got on the hotline man
but I just wanted to kind of uh to wrap
it up right there again you can come and
see we got some great dates coming up
Pittsburgh next weekend Colusa casino
near Chico California New York City
Nashville if you have friends in any of
these cities man send them out to the
show
you know I need all the support I can
get you know because the truth is I go
to these clubs if people don't come out
they don't have me back so you know I'm
not begging or anything but I am
shooting me straight man I'm letting you
guys know the truth I'm let you know the
truth man Stark County Illinois and
that's a fundraiser show we're raising
money to open a theater there San Diego
the House of Blues Las Vegas all before
the end of July tickets at Theo von comm
slash tour tou R and I just want to wish
everybody happy Memorial Day thank you
guys for supporting the podcast again
that was the hotline to basically
suggestions or you can text if somebody
we're going to check in about missing
appendages and what that's like and I
know I still owe you got some episodes
about manhood and some stuff about the
future and we'll get to it man I'm doing
the best that I can just been out on the
road and I get caught up my feelings out
here some and sometimes it's kind of
hectic but um have a Memorial Day
everyone
you guys be good to yourselves I'm going
to take us out right here with a little
bit of the national anthem again
[Music]
say does that star-spangled banner yet
with the land
[Music]
alright guys happy Memorial Day
and I want to thank everybody that does
make these calls into the hotline dude
thank you guys so much man I can't you
know I respect all you guys being
willing to share your thoughts and
feelings and and I'm not offering advice
yeah I don't have any real advice we you
know we got to remember to frame that
properly I'm just offering some
suggestions you know I don't have the
gospel I don't know it you know I can
just try and you know and try and share
if there's something that I've
experienced I'm trying my best I'm not
perfect if you need serious help get
serious help man because I'm getting
serious help on the side this is helping
us we're helping each other but I'm
getting serious help on the side and I
love you guys thank you so much I'll see
y'all next time
thank you for this past weekend